Kit möchte da wir Fans das gerade
diskutiert haben gewisst wie
gewissen wie würdest du denn du deine
Musikrichtung in einen eine sch Schu
Schublade packen
müsstest müsste sie
bezeichnen ist es Rock Pop Rock
Pop ja die ganz tollen Schubladen in der
man in den man immer reingesteckt
wird das ich glaube das mag kein
Künstler aber
ich wir versuchen einfach eine gute
Mischung einfach hinzubekommen und
einfach einfach das was uns Spaß macht
und was wir spielen möchten aber ich ich
ich glaube dass
oder ich denke dass eine eine rockp
Mischung immer dabei ist und ja die
macht uns auf jeden Fall Spaß und da
stehen wir auf jeden Fall auch hinter
die letzte Frage kommt von mir in
sarbrücken hat ein kameraarm oder wie
das heißt
mitgefilmt die Videos sind auf sevenload
zu sehen kommt er auch auf der Tour zum
Einsatz können wir vielleicht diesmal
mit professionellen Konzertaufnahmen
ergänzen zu den Audio Mitschnitten von
Konzert online rechnen steht noch nicht
fest
das also auf dieser Tour auf jeden Fall
nicht es gab ja jetzt in
relinghausen diese diese
konster online Sticks zu zu zu kaufen
und die haben wir halt aufgenommen aber
so eine DVD die
die da ist noch die Überlegung ob ob wir
das vielleicht auf nächstes Jahr dann
verschieben